So here's a typical group of friends in middle
school. And some of the people are popular, some of
them might not be. The first step to deciding
who's popular, is looking at who has a lot of
friends. So let's draw in some links, that show
who's a friend. And friendship links are one directional. Just
because Alice's friends with Bob, doesn't mean that Bob
is friend with Alice. So we'll draw our links as
arrows, so this means this person, we'll call him Bob, is
friends with Alice. And let's say, Alice
has many friends. And let's say Bob is also friends with
this person, they're friends with each other.
We have lots of friendship links. Some
of them are bi-directional but not all of them. So, we have lots of friendships.
So, is this enough to decide who's popular. So, if you
went to a school like I did, it's not. Just having a
lot of friends is not enough to make you popular, you
have to have the right friends. You have to be friends with
the popular people. So, it's not enough to have lots of
geeky friends say in high school, you've gotta have lots of friends
that are popular. So that means the definition of popular, isn't
just about having lots of friends, it's about having lots of friends,
who also have lots of friends. That's what
make some one popular, so we can define
popularity of a person is the number of
people who are friends with p. This means
the number of links from someone else to
that person is their popularity score. So here
is Charlie, so there are one, two, three
links into Charlie, so Charlie's popularity score would
be three. Alice also has three links, so her
popularity score would also be three. Bob only has one
arrow going to Bob, so his popularity score would be
one. So, this isn't a bad way to define popularity,
but it's not quite right. So, the definition of popularity
doesn't just depend on the number of friends you have,
it depends on, both, the number, and the popularity of
your friends. So, we can change the definition. Let's instead
define the popularity score of a person p. Now
it's going to be the sum of the popularities of
all of their friends. So we can write that in
a mathematical way, so using the sigma means to sum
up. We're going to take each friend, that is in
the friends of p. And we're going to sum up the
popularity score of the friends. If the mathematical notation is
unfamiliar to you, we could also write this as pseudo
Python code. We're thinking of the popularity of
a person p. Let's assume we have a
function that gives us the friends. So we're
going to start with a score of zero. We're going to
loop through the friends. And for each friend,
we're going to add to p score, the popularity score
of the friend. And we'll return the score
as the result. So now, you've seen a mathematical
definition of popularity, you've seen the same thing as code. I'm going to ask
you a very important quiz question next. Its an easy one to get
right if you try it twice because there's only two answers, but think
about it carefully. See if you can get it right the first time.